ce sont des choses les choses ne se
passent pas vous dire c'est qu'on va
vous faire un aussi
bonne émission bien tu
télévision française am pour toi qui va
venir aussi et qu est ce qui m pokora
il veut juste une photo de moi juste une
photo de moi
eh bien donc vous avez dit quesnel
regarder ça ça sexy c est ce que vous
avez dit au public où ils vivront en
ville vivre un truc de fou et vous chers
a dit vivre un truc de truc de fou déjà
c'est un truc à vous dis là tout de
suite là en début d'émission
hier j'ai une idée voilà vous allez voir
je vais vous faire un cadeau de tous les
jours je vais l'annoncer la en première
partie d'émission et vous vous savez
même pas de quoi il s'agit
non non mais ça vous bravo et j'ai pas
eu un cadeau d'anniversaire
le seul qui m'a pas qu'annoncer camille
combal toujours quand vous avez des
cadeaux mais au moins on a des cadeaux
nous avons des cadeaux pour vous tout le
monde ici à des cadeaux pour vous à
commencer par thierry c'est quoi thierry
mon livre de chevet c'est 1000 de mes
meilleures blagues c'est quoi le livre
de mes meilleures blagues quand vous
savez vos vies
scénariste de ce fait qu'elle est sympa
mais moi qui adore la lecture merci hier
jean-michel aussi qu'à quelques
exposants c'est quoi le bal le livre que
j'ai le plus précieux c'est l'annuaire
de toutes mes ex la deux
témoin les cages jaune juste dans
wozzeck sa da silva plomberie c'est
normal
oui valérie match bien dari ramé tenait
aussi à faire un cadeau à temps et c'est
sincère parce que je pensais avoir perdu
à nrj 12 est en fait c'est ici que ça se
passe et non c'est ma dignité mais
n'était pas loin même si c'est vraiment
la dignité de match
c'est dingue ça ce genre de vans a
marché sur une année
si vraiment on a changé complètement de
dominique quoi c'est vraiment à côté de
la plaque quoi pour savoir qu'est ce
qu'un halo yahia gilou regarder il
poursuit que des canaux de gagner comme
ça
on voit que les gens sachent mais qu'est
ce qui la met à votre avis mais c'est
quoi une nappe amène un mouchoir font
mouche lorsqu'il ya un grand nez oui je
vous laisse la vanne était très bonne
mais mal vendus et mal vendus et ouais
merci
c'est hier quadrophenia mois moi j'ai
pensé à un cadeau possible parce que je
sais que vous aimez beaucoup de la
grande littérature ou la collection dit
oui alors j'ai pensé à la collection de
martin merci martin apprend la danse de
l'épaule n'en faut
et marquer que des costes-rouges molette
si martine fait du couscous bullet man
c'est très marrant c'est pas du tout
raciste merci beaucoup regardé après un
formateur le bart une feinte à gillot
babouche pour partir